throughout the pandemic businesses have
been enforcing of course that mandate
and now some are welcoming the idea of
just ditching those masks Joe Mohler is
live He's spoken to a few local
businesses today and joins us right near
the pepper mill on the strip
Brian Denise whether you're going out on
the Strip or you're walking into a
grocery store you still got to put these
masks on but soon a change could be near
here in Nevada
there's some people that walk in without
the mask on throughout the pandemic
business owners and their employees have
been forced to ask customers to follow
the state's mask mandate and it has not
always been easy we try and stay out of
that confrontation sort of thing owners
like Ignacio cesa will be paying close
attention to what governor Steve sisolac
has to say come Thursday I would love to
see the masked man-made loosen up a
little bit
he owns The Omelette house in Summerlin
and Sky Canyon at this state and time
I'm not really concerned about going
backwards I mean we've done everything
possible to tackle this so like I said
it's been two years now I mean we need
we need to uh we need to move forward
Mark Kennedy from Vegas document sewing
has seen it all most people come in and
they go oops I forgot my mask and I
think they're testing me somewhat he
says he doesn't know what else we can do
to fight the virus in my opinion I feel
like just let it do its thing with cases
down he thinks we are in a safe place my
opinion I think it should be an option
if somebody doesn't want to wear it I
don't think they should have to wear it
back out here live we went into a couple
of businesses and restaurants and they
all said basically the same thing many
people want to see this Mass mandate go
away they all said they'll be paying
close attention to what happens tomorrow
reporting live on the Strip this evening
Joe molder live local now